immer wieder finden forschungsteams
weltweit hinweise darauf dass
gänseblümchen auf der wiese oder die
küchenkräuter in ihrer küche mehr können
als einfach nur grün zu sein und zu
wachsen es scheint manchmal so als
hätten sie eine art seelenleben es gibt
einige expertinnen und experten die
überzeugt davon sind dass pflanzen
gefühle haben und ein gedächtnis ihr
habt euch dieses thema dieses hoch
spannenden thema bei whatsapp gewünschte
bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts zum
thema können sich pflanzen tot stellen
oder freuen sie sich über frisches
wasser und was hat das all das mit dem
lügendetektor des amerikanischen
geheimdienstes zu tun jetzt den klicks
zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
erst vor kurzem haben wir hier über die
theorie des sogenannten wood wide web
berichtet das internet des waldes denn
mittlerweile steht fest bäume
kommunizieren nicht nur über duft
botschaften sondern auch über pilze
konkret handelt es sich um sogenannte
mykorrhiza weiße pilzfäden die
tatsächlich mit dem fein wurzelsystem
der bäume kontakt aufnehmen und
botschaften an andere pflanzen sträucher
und bäume übermitteln konkret
transportieren sie wasser kohlenstoff
und nährstoffe zwischen den bäumen hin
und her und zwar ganz individuell
abgestimmt auf die verschiedenen
bedürfnisse dazu der zellbiologe
frantisek baluska von der universität
bonn beuel haben ihre eigenen probleme
ihre eigenen fähigkeiten mit problemen
umzugehen schon sehr früh hatte der
amerikaner keith baxter die idee von
solchen fähigkeiten der pflanzen er
hatte in den frühen 50er jahren für den
amerikanischen geheimdienst eine
lügendetektor schule gegründet
mittlerweile gilt er als vater der
pflanzen kommunikation aber wie passt
das zusammen ganz einfach in einer
winternacht im jahr 1966 kam tief baxter
auf die idee sein neues lügendetektor
verfahren auch an seiner büro pflanze zu
testen
wie reagiert der drachenbaum wohl was
zeigt der schreiber des lügendetektor
sven mann der pflanze wasser gibt wächst
erwartete eine kurve die einen kleineren
elektrischen widerstand anzeigt denn die
pflanze sollte eine bessere
leitfähigkeit haben wenn sie gerade
frisch gegossen wurde dazu baxter ich
weiß nicht mehr wie so aber aus
irgendeinem grund wollte ich wissen wie
lange wohl das wasser brauchen würde um
aus dem wurzelbereich bis ganz nach oben
in die spitzen der blätter zu gelangen
doch die kurve die ihm dann angezeigt
wurde ließ ihm den atem stocken es war
genau die typische kurve die das gerät
anzeigte wenn menschen positiv erregt
worden waren
die pflanze freute sich also über das
wasser baxter verbrachten die ganze
nachbar samen drachenbaum in einem
nächsten test wollte er die pflanze
bedrohen also dachte er daran ein blatt
an zu brennen wechselt zufolge reagiert
die pflanze bereits in diesem moment
äußerst krass also bereits in der
sekunde als er nur daran dachte die
pflanze zu verletzen hatte die pflanze
ist also bemerkt dass man sie in
gedanken
bedrohte griff baxter ging also los um
streichhölzer zu holen wieder zeigte der
lügendetektor eine angst kurve einen
schwächeren ausschlag folgte dann als
besser ein blatt an fackelte doch der
amerikaner bekam es nicht übers herz
seine pflanze zu verbrennen und so tat
er in den darauf folgenden versuchen nur
noch so als wolle er den drachen baum
verletzten die pflanze reagierte gar
nicht wahr der drachenbaum also
tatsächlich in der lage zu verstehen
wann er ernsthaft in gefahr ist und wann
die bedrohung nur ein testlauf ist die
aufzeichnung des lügendetektor von den
reaktionen des drachen baum schmückten
kurze zeit später wächst das wand und
der chl mitarbeiter ging noch weiter
denn er wollte testen ob seine pflanze
auch die gedanken und gefühle anderer
lebewesen lesen kann
dazu ließ er leben des schirms in
kochendes wasser werfen und ja der baum
hatte mitleid zudem fand heraus dass die
hühnereier schmerzempfinden wenn sie
gekocht werden und salatblätter in todes
starre fallen kurz bevor sie gegessen
werden
und auch heute noch gibt es einige
forschungsteams die sich becks hat
zumindest in teilen anschließen es ist
also keine wissenschaftlich bestätigte
lehrmeinung also ganz wichtig aber laut
diesen forschungsteams haben pflanzen
gefühle können sich erinnern und
optische und akustische eindrücke
wahrnehmen und auch menschen aus
buddhistischen ländern sind auf baxter
seite doch nicht nur die cia kritisierte
baxter für seine experimente auch die
meisten forschungsteams weltweit sehen
seine ergebnisse nicht und tatsächlich
bisher konnten becks dass ergebnisse
nicht wirklich in experimenten
reproduziert werden wenn er als erstes
neues über das geheime leben der
pflanzen und zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei wurden dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt
ihr direkt über mich in der redaktion
von klicks zum mitmachen und mir themen
vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen
teilnehmen und somit bestimmen was sie
auf tricks um läuft und es gibt auch ein
kleines goodie am anfang der direkte
draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es
weiter dafür auch draufklicken mit
können pflanzen denken ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran